I want to run an unattended long running
batch job in the cloud without having to
configure servers you should try out
Cloud run
[Music]
jobs so karolina you are a product
manager for cloud run that's right
recently I've been focusing on making it
easier to run unattended jobs on cloud
run without having to set up or manage
servers
perfect I have codee here that should
run every night it reads a large text
file uh it does some lookups for each
line and then inserts the values in a
database uh but it takes several hours
to run can I use cloud run for that yes
you can we recently increased the
maximum length of jobs so they can run
for up to 24 hours and it's simple to
deploy jobs because you don't have to
set up any servers also you're only
Built for the time that the job actually
runs sounds great Carolina uh now I've
created a good Cloud project already uh
would you help me deploy it um deploy my
code as a cloud run job sure so first
run g-cloud run jobs deploy set task
timeout to 24 hours and specify where
your source code is if you're happy with
the default timeout of 10 minutes you
can skip the task timeout
parameter okay uh the job is being
deployed
now looks like it's done and if I go to
the cloud console and then Cloud uh
run then
jobs I see my newly deployed job uh and
I can even click here to run
it very good uh so kolina what if I want
to schedule this to run unattended in
the middle of the
night then You' click
triggers and add schedule a trigger
very good I want my uh job to run uh
every midnight UTC so I enter the cron
tab expression for that
here then I click
create all done uh so this is great I
can run my job that takes many hours
what if my job takes more than 24 hours
well you could parallelize your job so
that it completes Faster by default your
job runs as a single unit but if you set
the tasks parameter to 100 for example
it'll start 100 parallel instances of
your code so my code would drawn 100
parallel tasks each doing 1% of the work
uh how would each task figure out which
records which one% it should process to
help with that each task is aware of its
task index and the total number of tasks
and based on that your code can
calculate which database records each
task should process excellent kolina uh
let's wrap this up what are the
takeaways you can run your unattended
jobs like data conversions or cleanups
in Cloud run jobs you won't need to set
up or maintain any servers and you'll
only pay for the time your job is
actually running and now your jobs may
run for up to 24 hours but just as
before you can easily run your code AS
multiple parallel tasks thanks for
showing me this Carolina thanks for
having Martin and thank you everyone for
watching if you have any questions for
kolina or me please post them below uh
also let me know if there are any other
servess topics you'd like to hear about
in future episodes I read every single
comment until next
[Music]
time